it's rare for the SCP Foundation to
encounter an anomaly that volunteers
information about itself that seems to
actively desire to be studied to be
investigated to be known but scp-082 is
one such anomaly
scp-082 calls himself Ferdinand a giant
man with an even bigger appetite and
though he is cheerful and chatty even
friendly by SCP foundation's standards
it can be difficult to sort the fact
from the fiction where his life story is
concerned at various points in his
containment he has claimed to be a
vampire a homunculus Sherlock Holmes
Alexander the Great Dr Frankenstein and
his monster Napoleon and Big Bird to
name a few but on October 27 2016
Ferdinand made a particular unusual
request he asked for a set of poetry
books a stack of blank paper and a quill
he isolated himself for days refusing to
drink or sleep as he wrote page after
page when he was finished he had written
a poem that seemed to be the first
honest exploration of his life story
since he was first contained by the
foundation it can be difficult to
determine when scp-082 is lying since he
is always grinning widely and claims to
only lie when it is through his teeth
but after reading the aforementioned
poem aloud he wept openly in what seemed
to be a genuine display of emotion
according to the events described in the
poem which should be taken with a small
grain of salt this is what ferdinand's
life was like before he became
scp-082 Ferdinand could not remember his
earliest years what his parents or his
childhood home might have looked like
his earliest memory was of a makeshift
home in an Alleyway a box to sleep in
and a bundle of rags serving as a
makeshift bed for food he would steal
the old bread thrown out by a nearby
Bakery and catch birds and rats that
were slow enough for him to Graham even
as a young boy he was enormous three
times the size of other boys his age his
strength and stature made him appealing
to the workhouses at first but they
always ended up throwing him out calling
him a monster the monster after the
third workhouse chased him into the
streets with whips he resigned himself
to a solitary life in the shadows down
the abandoned Alleyways were not even
the Beggars would go so overrun were
they with rats and filth it was better
for Ferdinand that way no one would try
to mock him to hurt him to dispose of
the monster once and for all he spent
his days and nights there in the little
Alleyway he had turned into a home
keeping as quiet as possible out of fear
that he would be discovered by someone
with ill intentions one night he got his
hands on a row of meat Tarts left on a
windowsill and ate to his heart's
content he slept unusually soundly that
night with a full belly for the first
time in a long time and without knowing
it he must have had begun to snore as
the first soft beams of sunlight fell
across his face stirring him from Sleek
he heard the sound of a strange man's
voice perhaps it was someone just
passing by on a nearby street but no
there was a shadow at the end of the
alleyway blocking out some of the light
he retreated out of sight hoping to
avoid detection but he could see two
more blurry figures stepping into his
vision all of a sudden they started
running towards him at top speed this
was no accidental encounter they had
spotted him and were targeting him
specifically for what he didn't want to
find out the giant boy climbed to his
feet and tried to run but the alley was
narrow and the three men grabbed hold of
each of his arms while one grabbed his
legs and forced him to the ground
someone stuffed a dirty rag into his
mouth muffling his cries for help and
out of the corner of his eye he saw the
glint of a metal pipe swinging at his
head then everything went dark when
Fernand opened his eyes again all he
could see was red Vivid red on all sides
as his vision adjusted he realized he
could see metal bars as well the red was
fabric right cloth draped over the iron
cage that now held him prisoner he
stumbled to his feet forced to stoop to
avoid bumping his head on the top of the
cage and rattled the bars desperately
let me out please
he begged though he felt as though it
was useless his plea was not met with
silence however but with loud cheerful
music he covered his ears at the sudden
noise jumping back but it came from all
sides and there was no Escape suddenly
his eyes were blinded by a sudden bright
light as the red cloth was yanked from
the cage in one swoop it took a moment
for his eyes to adjust but as he blinked
the tears from his eyes Ferdinand could
make out a man with a large mustache a
long red and gold coat a matching top
hat and a gold-tipped cane the man
grinned at him but it was not a friendly
face the smile did not reach his eyes
which glinted with a cold cruel Delight
behind the ringmaster Ferdinand could
now see a crowd sitting men women and
children all watching him with rapturous
Fascination a mix of intrigue disgust
and horror on their faces he looked from
face to face seeking any kindness any
sympathy but found not one who looked as
if they might help him escape the music
climbed to a crescendo and when it
stopped the ringmaster spoke ladies and
gentlemen boys and girls
I have brought you something the likes
of which no one has ever seen before I
have traveled the world in search of
oddities and Curiosities to delight and
shock you with and after Crossing every
ocean exploring the furthest reaches of
the globe I have brought you a very
special gift do not be afraid the Beast
will not harm you I will ensure that you
are all perfectly safe should he try
anything at all one of my helpers here
he gestured to one of two large men
standing on either side of the cage each
brandishing an ax
Fernand recoiled at the threat but there
was nowhere for him to go in the cramped
cage already a bit too small for his
massive body the ringmaster continued
his speech pacing back and forth in
front of the cage and running his Cane
across the bars with a horrible
clattering sound
as you can see this creature looks like
a boy but his statue reveals the truth
it is something else entirely something
bigger stronger more vicious than any
child could ever be you see the legs
like great tree trunks the arms strong
enough to wrestle a bear but do not dear
audience neglect to notice its Mighty
Jaws like steel strong enough to crush
anything it bites down on strong enough
to crack through bone and the teeth
enormous and pearly white with a smile
bright enough to light up the darkness
what do you say Beast will you give the
people a smile Fernand coward in the
cage watching everything with wide
frightened eyes he certainly did not
feel like smiling when he did not budge
the ringmasters flacked his Cane against
the bars making another horrible
metallic clang well these people paid
good money to be here to not keep them
waiting after another moment of silence
and Fernand remains stocks still the
audience began to boo tossing empty
popcorn bags and insults at the cage the
ringmaster leaned in close and whispered
smile for the people or I'll see to it
you suffer Agony you could only dream of
this threat snapped Ferdinand out of his
Frozen Terror and standing as tall as he
could in the little cage he smiled wide
showing all of his many many teeth at
once the audience erupt into cheers at
the site and the band played triumphant
horns as the ringmaster basked in the
Applause
about that the ringmaster took off his
hat and bowed low to the ground holding
out his hat for the audience to toss in
coins in a token of their appreciation
for an excellent show by the time the
applause was finished his hat was filled
with shiny silver and gold he tossed the
Hat now heavy with New Wealth to one of
the guards and pulled a gold-handled
whip from his pocket
he cracked the whip ominously then
turned toward the cage he cracked the
whip again this time across ferdinand's
back the boy roared in pain a great
bellowing sound that carried from miles
around and he fell to his knees the
sound was so loud so powerful that the
audience was terrified small children
began to cry and people poured from the
circus tent in a panic afraid the Beast
would break free and tear them apart but
there was no Beast only a frightened boy
who did not understand his own strength
crying at the cruelty the world had
shown him all his life once they were
alone the ringmaster turned to Ferdinand
again catching his eye
you're crying boy from here on out
you'll be coming with me together we're
going to be very very rich and I will
make you a star whether you want to be
one or not and for a time that became
fernand's life night after night crammed
into a cage fed on chicken bones and
leftover scraps paraded in front of an
uncaring audiences as the ringmaster
tormented him showing him off as a
sideshow attraction and forcing him to
smile with the threat of the ax or the
whip his fellow circus folk were not
much Kinder than the ring Master either
the clown sprayed him with water and
taunted him through the bars the animal
trainers threatened to pit him against
their lions and see who came out alive
only one person ever showed Ferdinand an
ounce of kindness at the circus a
bearded lady who would sing opera songs
in a beautiful clear soprano her voice
was the loveliest thing Ferdinand had
ever heard a tiny Slice of Heaven in the
hell his life had become days LED
together as the tour went on a stretch
of seemingly endless days and nights
until the day of the last show came he
looked up at the thin slivers of night
sky visible through the gaps in the tent
the twinkling of stars just Out Of Reach
what would become of him after the tour
ended what Horrors awaited him next
would he just sit there and take it or
would he finally do something to bring
it all into a close he flexed his
muscles quietly taking notice of how he
had grown over the past few months
regular feedings more than he had gotten
on the street had bulked him up
considerably he now stowed at over seven
feet tall and could feel that his
strength had doubled or even tripled the
show began as it usually did with the
crack of the ringmaster's whip but
suddenly the man stepped forward and
began a speech he had never made before
great Beast
hunger behold as I set it free and to
Ferdinand shock the ringmaster unlocked
the door to the cage and swung it open
he took a tentative step out standing at
his full height for the first time in
months as he stretched his spine
straight see how it is tamed go on now
boy smile for your public they've been
so good to us he jabbed ferdinand's ribs
with his Cane hard enough to leave a
dark purple bruise you heard me smile
the whip cracked again and the audience
began to boo and jeer throwing their
garbage at Ferdinand a bag hit his cheek
with a slap and a deep dark rage finally
awoke beneath the months of Terror you
remember our agreement do as I say or I
shall cut off something you'll miss
before the ringmaster could say another
word Ferdinand grabbed him and pulled
him into a bone-crushing embrace the
man's voice came out in a squeak peace
what are you doing that is not my name
Ferdinand bellowed and he opened his
mouth wide wider than he ever had before
and gobbled up the ringmaster in three
quick bites the audience screamed
fleeing from their seats but Ferdinand
moved faster than they did he grabbed
person after person starting with those
that had been the cruelest and shouted
the most insulting things and devoured
them one by one when he was full he ran
into the night into the forest and did
not stop until he was free he bathed in
the river washing away all that he had
done and remained there for quite some
time feeding on passerbys when his
hunger got the better of him his sense
of time grew fuzzy then and he could not
be sure how long he spent there but word
of missing townspeople eventually
reached a special organization one
dedicated to studying those like him and
for the second time in his life
Ferdinand was taken into custody by
strangers however these scientists were
much kinder to him and never called him
a beast they simply gave him a number
scp-082 want to own an SCP of your own
go to scpswag.com for premium anomalous
merchandise now go and check out scp-082
Ferdinand the cannibal and scp-001 can
scp-049 finally cure when day breaks for
more bizarre and disturbing Ferdinand
antics